Could waiting to have kids be the key to a
long life? Ask me again in 60 years.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and it's no
secret that we live in an age where women
are trying to have it all. We have jobs, we
have hobbies - but where do children come
in? My parents always ask me. Well it turns
out waiting to have kids - may not be such
a bad things after all.
A new study from the Boston University School
of Medicine has found that women who wait
to have children later in life - may actually
live longer than women who don't.
This study was published in this month's issue
of Menopause, and is based on data collected
from the Long Life Family Study - which is
an ongoing study of 551 different families
with members who've lived exceptionally long
lives.
They looked at 462 women from those families,
and determined how long they lived to be,
as well as the age at which they had their
last child. Turns out - women who gave birth
to their last child after the age of 33, were
twice as likely to live to age 95 or older,
than women who had their last child by age
29.
Previous studies on this topic have found
similar results, including one that showed
that women who give birth to a child after
age 40 are 4 times more likely to live to
100 years old.
Scientists warn that while this doesn't mean
women should wait to have children just to
improve their chances of living longer - it
does highlight the important relationship
between aging and fertility. Being able to
have children at an older age, indicates that
a woman's reproductive system is aging slowly
- so it makes sense that the rest of her body
would as well.
With that in mind, it's also believed that
women may be the driving force behind our
ever-increasing longevity. If a woman has
the right combination of genetic variants,
that can slow down the aging process and decrease
the risk for age-related genes - then her
chances of passing those genes down to her
children, will also increase. Leading to offspring
with longer life expectancies than the rest
of the population.
Given that over 85% of the people who live
to be 100, are women - this study sheds even
more light on how awesome and amazing our
gender really is. No editorializing whatsoever.
And while we're on the topic of awesome ladies,
let me remind you of one of my favorite women
in recent history, Tina Fey. Her book Bossypants
is all about being a working mother in Hollywood.
It's one of the funniest books I've ever read,
and you can get it for free, TODAY - on audible.com.
Audible is the leading provider of downloadable
digital audiobooks and spoken word entertainment.
They've got over 100,000 titles to choose
from, so whether you like comedy, sci-fi,
nonfiction, young adult, whatever tickles
your fancy - they've got it. And it's super
easy to use - all of their books can be downloaded
to your iPod or MP3 player and played back
anywhere, anytime.
Go to audiblepodcast.com/dnews to get a FREE
Audiobook-download of your choice when you
sign up today - and remember, every sign-up
helps support the show, which we REALLY do
appreciate. So again, head over to Audiblepodcast.com/dnews
for your Free Audiobook download!
In the meantime, if you have questions, comments,
anything you wanna say about this episode
- leave em in the comments below. Otherwise,
thanks for watching!